hey last thing you just mentioned
being in a box 23 hours a day one hour
out
for people who don't realize it's
solitary
that's got to be what is that like man
and how hard is it to stay
sane in a situation like i should have
drive you crazy you feel me
if you just some people just
you know some people
can't be by themselves some people can't
do that [ __ ] you know i mean i should
drive them crazy
i'm saying but when i was in there i
just like
you know that [ __ ] was crazy bro like
you were here you
this is madness a mad house everybody uh
people fishing throwing you know people
just as well and and you and you don't
leave that cell
and and with the box i was in you don't
come outside you
like like this is the cell they build
another unit right here right
this is like a little door right and you
walk out of your cell
and there's another little box like this
with a gate
with fresh air so you walk from out
yourself
to that little [ __ ] patio type [ __ ]
right and all you get is just that air
like like just and that's it you know
what i'm saying so it was 23 hours
of that like and so
does that hour include like you
showering and all that type of [ __ ] or
is that
well the jail hour this yeah yeah so the
spot
the showers don't turn on all the time
they turn it on
when when it's time for rec and when
you're in solitaire are you alone or do
you have a selly
well it depends some some spots is
you're alone
some spots you have a selly so what
would you do like to
just get through it was it reading is it
sleeping a lot
like you know what i'm saying like right
i was
i i read i read a lot i was like you
know
push-ups you know [ __ ] whatever i could
do you know i'm saying
you know talking to my bunkie playing
chess
you know what i mean i i fought a bunch
of monkeys you know what i'm saying like
you know
um just i and i did i see i did
i did 16 months
um i did 16 months of that [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying
[ __ ] on rikers island before you feel me
but that was single you know what i'm
saying so
you were by yourself for 16 months every
day right 23 hours a day well
i did i did so what happened was they
gave me
they gave me 20 months of that right
and then like on my like ninth month
i went upstate you know what i'm saying
and then i went back down
and then i did more months like so i had
a break but i did like nine ten months
straight to that [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying by myself would you just try to
sleep
as much as you could through the day you
you made you make a [ __ ] like a
schedule
you know what i'm saying so you can't
sleep the whole [ __ ] day you know
what i'm saying but
you know you get up you know you do your
push-ups
you feel me you eat your breakfast you
feel me you read your book
you know what i mean you talk [ __ ] on
the gate and then you just try to
keep a regiment you know what i'm saying
keep a regiment keep a [ __ ] like
you know what i mean and then you i'll
try to read as much as i can
i try to write as much as i can i just
use my time
to you know a lot of people don't though
a lot of people just be there beating a
dick
you know what i'm saying doing dumb [ __ ]
talking wild [ __ ] on the gate
you know what i'm saying and come out
box monsters you feel me like
you know crazy [ __ ] like yeah
cause i can imagine like that could go
one of two ways you could either come
out of that like a lot stronger
you got to be strong or you could come
out of there
crazy kind of crazy kind of crazy full
crazy
full [ __ ] that [ __ ] that [ __ ] crazy
because you'll meet those people who got
out of prison right and they're just
like
it didn't help it got [ __ ] whatever was
there got way worse
right [ __ ] was he walked in he
walked in crazy came out
[ __ ] psycho